I know you've been traveling to China
for 40 years now how bad is it really 20
years only I'm not that old but I've
probably been there more than 40 times
what we saw in the third plenum two
years ago when when this new government
came in and said we are going to change
things we are going to centralize the
government we are going to stop the
local governments from this crazy
overspending this was the first time I
ever went through China and I saw it I
saw so many Idol cranes you drive around
the cities we were in some of the the
second-tier cities and you really saw
the slowdown when we talked to
executives what they told us is look
it's the numbers we are seeing and the
numbers coming out of China are really
bad new housing starts are down 18% it's
even worse than that is what they're
privately telling us there really has
been a slowdown you can see it in the
stock market people aren't investing in
real estate anymore they're taking their
money for fear of losing it in the real
estate market and putting it in the
stock market so the money is there is
just moving differently but from a
metals and mining analysts standpoint
the way you know we look at the world
it's having a major impact on iron ore
on copper on steel etc so can the
government of course says that the
economy is still growing at a seven
percent clip what's your takeaway how
much worse is the slowdown and the
government says well I mean how they
come up with the seven percent numbers
hard to tell I think about 70 percent of
their GDP has been construction their
number their own numbers say
constructions down about 18 percent so
how they come up with that seven percent
I don't know we'll just say from a
metals and mining standpoint things
there are bleak and they seem to be
getting worse all right from a metals
and mining standpoint how far away is
the bottom here it's very hard to tell I
mean everyone is waiting for China to go
back to what the old regime did which
the old regime would say hey we're
having all sorts of problems we're going
to put out a you know a huge
infrastructure boom and whenever you see
prices move up you'll see a lot of
rumors hey they're going to announce
something we don't know but this
government seems serious they seem like
they want to have a new China they want
to have a China that adds value they
want to have a new
that doesn't recklessly pollute the way
they've done in the past I really give
credit for this government they're
taking very very brave steps out in the
world today and I think it's changing
the entire dynamic of China long term
it's probably the right thing to do but
you rarely see government's make such a
bold move and stick to their stick to
what their plan is
and a China really seems to do that I
think that's fantastic for China long
term but short term it's really giving a
lot of issues to China and that's why
you see the price of iron ore down 60 70
% that's why you've seen a lot of the
other metal prices all in bear markets
and China which is half of the world's
demand for metals is suffering but long
term it probably is really good for the
Chinese people and the Chinese economy